bonjour bonsoir et bien cette émission
spéciale dite est un magazine qui a lieu
ce soir en direct sur tf1 sera consacrée
est fini mais qu'est-ce que les
carnavals et celle ci voulait que cette
émission spéciale dite est un magazine
sera consacré ce soir à une
rétrospective des principaux événements
qui ont marqué l'année 1975 principaux
événements qui seront illustrés ce soir
par des chansons en 1975 a montré les
prostituées au grand jour et je vous
propose d'aller maintenant faire un tour
du côté de ces dames grâce à notre ami
d'elle
je
il ya loin sur mon jour d'hui
mais il m'arrive souvent quand j'étais
encore cet adolescent
je ne sais plus
le säntis
/
en deux
oui
de sa fille de
coincé raison
mais qui en fait de leur mieux comment
rendre plus vieux
j'irai me
ok
non
sur le
seul
et nous
je
oh
et pour
cher
seul
le temps
alors
là
j'aimerais bien
je ne
mais moi seule
ce temps
le temps
alors
oh
1975 année de la femme et des
prostituées mais surtout années de la
femme et c'est la raison pour laquelle
est bien la femme libérée peu enfin
mener son homme par le bout du nez et
jean ferrat est le premier à le
reconnaître
il me faudrait apprendre à vie
bettman
oui
il va découvrir la terre
et moi qui avient que dans la neige
chiche je suis loin
dans la dette
10 grâce à ma femme je suis riche
je
ma poule et a toujours raison
elle voit plus haut sur et ses talents
mais la friture et son rayon
by son fourneau dans la maison
grâce au poulet
dragons
ma femme se retenir son nom
oui bien on me rappelle à l'instant 1975
fut surtout l'année de valéry giscard
d'estaing puisque de mémoire de français
on n'avait jamais été aussi informés sur
un président de la république avec
giscard jj pour les intimes
ce qui fait dire à pierre perret que
désormais nous savons tout sur le jjd
corps au gay ou gay s'approche du
tableau doive on va peut-être à face à
voir quel est ce monstre sacré qui
attend de pouvoir des choses et idées
nous décident
so servent-ils la bourse qu'ils dévient
de vous s'arrête sur m6 sur dans le beau
le vrai le faux le dur le mouret picsou
lescure basée au cap pelé le bel athlète
le pique assiette que des théories
directes seul et j'ai dit bientôt
en fait il n'y a pas de barrage à la
télévision je maintenant vous laisser
avec les deux énergumènes qui ont fait
irruption tout à l'heure soit rolandeau
et luis antonio mieux connu et brésil
sous le nom des étoiles